bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 78 très
largement consacré au 1er novembre dans
quelques instants avec le père Christan
Dioré nous évoquerons la période de la
tous sain et la symbolique pour tous les
catholiques et puis nous retrouvons
également Alice Gastine bonsoir pour
votre chronique écho on va pas forcément
parler d'un sujet gay mais enfin c'est
un suet de circonstances tout à fait
bonsoir Catherine on s'intéressera au
marché des pompes funèbres avec une
particularité cette année c'est la
hausse des demandes de crémation une
augmentation de 34 % dans les ivelines
et puis nous reviendrons en détail sur
les chiffres du chômage notamment dans
le département qui sont très mauvais
voilà rendez-vous dans une dizaine de
minutes et tout de suite le premier
invité de ce 78 le Père Christian
doré alors la tout sain c'est une fête
catholique qui est célébrée le 1er
novembre et qui n'est pas à confondre
avec le 2 novembre qui est la fête de
tous les défunts père Christian Dioré
bonsoir vous êtes le prêtre de la
paroiss de MPa et l'c alors d'abord
cette distinction entre le 1er novembre
qui est un jour férier et le 2 novembre
qui n'est pas férier mais c'est deux
fêtes oui c'est deux fêes il faut pas
confondre du tout he c'est 1er novembre
c'est une immense fête de l'amour en
fait c'est c'est c'est un amour qui est
détecté par les gens en disant celui-là
il vit vraiment de l'Évangile enfin il
est crédible hein et c'est pas c'est pas
symbolique contrairement à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est une réalité
c'est voilà des vrais gens qui ont vécu
des vraies vies et qui sont crédibles
pour les gens le 2 novembre c'est c'est
pas symbolique non plus c'est se dire
bah il y a aussi parmi nous des gens
qu'on aime bien ils sont là on les
oublie pas voilà ah mais c'est je dirait
l'un est affectueux et se souvient que
il y a une espérance à cause de la foi
des chrétiens sur la résurrection
l'autre c'est une super fête l'autre
c'est vraiment la fête des gens qu' on
pense qu'ils ont quand même pas mal
réussi leur choix leur art de vivre je
dirais je disais que c'était symbolique
parce que c'est une fête qui est
purement ces deux fêtes sont purement
catholiques elles ne sont pas
chrétiennes les protestants ne célèbrent
pas la toussin expliquez-nous pourquoi
d' c'est une grande tradition catholique
la raison elle a été que à force de
détecter si on peut dire la toussin
c'est un sondage en fait le peuple de
Dieu dans son bon sens a dit tiens
celui-là il a peut-être des faut il est
pas si mal que ça par rapport à il a
surtout des super qualités pour devenir
un saint euh il a des super qualités non
il a il a une super crédibilité sur un
point pas forcément sur tous mais
reconnu comme ça
alors les catholiques enfin c'est avant
les catholiques ça pendant beaucoup de
siècles on a détecté toutes sortes de
gens différents à un moment donné
c'était trop parce que c'était ces
gens-là devenaient quasiment des dieux
il y en a eu ralbol et euh Luther a dit
écoute on arrête tout ça c'est pas
sérieux Dieu est Dieu nom de Dieu hein
voilà hein lu les protestants et donc
les protestants se sont dé oui les
protestantisme a été agacé à mon avis à
juste titre sur des survalorisations de
gens au point que bah ils se devenaient
des espèces de demi-dieux d'accord vous
vous dites à juste titre comment vous
dites à juste titre c'est-à-dire on a
trop canonisé à ou eu à juste titre non
eux eux les protestants à juste titre
sont agacés de choses exagérées B faut
faut reconnaître ça quand même hein ce
qui fait que maintenant on est plus hble
quand même je pens donc la tous ça est
célébré que par les catholiques et la
fête des défuns donc qui est le 2
novembre qui est donc fait le moment où
on prie nos morts qui voilà c'est une
fête qui est également célébrée que par
les catholiques oui oui oui c'est dans
le cadre liturgique catholique c'est
l'un suit l'autre parce que justement il
y a tous ceux qu'on évoque avec force et
le lendemain on se dit attends et le
grand-père et et la vieille tante et et
le petit frère et on les embarque tous
dans dans la la fête des défs hein mais
c'est pour célébrer la résurrection pour
nous c'est pas du tout négatif hein
c'est vraiment la fête de la vie fel de
la mort et alors est-ce que la vie ce
qu'on voit sur ces images effectivement
les fleurissements de de tombes la vie
passe par les fleurs c'est sybol la vie
passe par les fleurs mais les fleurs
disent au-delà de de la peine bah tu
vois la mort n'a pas le dernier mot ben
c'est mais tout ça c'est centré sur la
personne de jésus-chris he il faudrait
pas oublier ça hein le le cœur de notre
foi c'est pas des bonnes idées hein
c'est de se dire bah voilà un humain et
qui dit Dieu à visage humain et quand on
dit Dieu à visage humain la mort n'a pas
le dernier mot elle a un mot mais pas le
dernier alors les fleurs bah disent ça
elles disent bah tu te rappelles ça
voilà je propose une une première on va
faire une première pause dans cet
entretien pierre di on va aller dans les
r de 50 ans en on demandé aux gens ce
que représentait pour eux la tousin on
écoute le
réponse les gens fleurissent tous les
cimetières la plupart du temps c'est ça
non c'est peut-être un souvenir des
personnes qu'on a perdu la fête des
morts et de tous les sains à tout ça
c'est la fête de tous les sains et c'est
les vacances pour les enfants et pour
les parents aussi la fête de tous les
saints la fête des morts la fête de ma
maman voilà c'est la fête des défunts je
pense voilà c'est tout pour moi voilà
c'est une fête religieuse la toussin ça
représente on pense beaucoup aux gens
qu'on a perdu hein la toussin d'après ma
culture c'est une fête catholique
maintenant il est vrai que c'est un peu
passé à l'ASS avec Halloween donc c'est
un peu dommage et quand on interroge les
enfants finalement ils retiennent plus
Halloween que la tous c'est une autre
culture mon anniversaire c'est tout
c'est mon anniversaire voilà bon
anniversaire à ce monsieur par contre ce
que dit la dame sur Halloween et là tout
ça ça do vous faire hurler non non ça me
fait rire parce que il y a il y a plus
beau que ça il y a Halloween mais il y a
hlywin he le saint gagne et en fait il y
a beaucoup de fêtes chrétiennes
catholiques lancé sur la région qui
s'appelle Holly win c'est pas halloween
c'est hollywin les sains gagne hein
c'est c'est franglais mais c'est beau
c'est pas une bataille mais non c'est
amusant c'est un défi à quand remonte
l'origine de ces deux fêtes he parce que
qu'on comprenne bien la tout sain le 1er
novembre et la commémoration des défin
le 2 novembre à quand remonte l'origine
de ces fêtes oh ça c'est il y a pas
d'origine précise ça c'est cristallisé
selon les les grands lieux de la
tradition chrétienne progressivement
autour 7 8 10e siècle quand quand les
choses se sont un peu reposé au niveau
des recherches théologiques on a s'est
arrêté là-dessus il y a pas eu ça bouge
beaucoup selon les églises aussi hein
parce que il y a des les églises ne sont
pas la liturgie est la même partout mais
il y a des traditions locales je
voudrais revenir sur la notion de de 5
qu'est-ce qu'un seint en fait voilà et
comment on le définit est-ce que est-ce
que alors question peut-être vous a j
peut-être un peu bête est-ce que
l'Église catholique continue à canoniser
encore des oui bien sûr il y en a eu
encore il y a jours un prêtre Jésu de
Madagascar il y en a il y en a Mme
plusieurs oui ben là ça c'est une
question de fond he là c'est intéressant
comme question la la vraie réponse c'est
que on est fasciné par la personne du
Christ je reviens à ça mais c'est ça
notre fascination et quand Jésus dit
heureux heureux ça veut dire en hébreu
en marche ça marche pour toi hein
heureux c'est si tu as un cœur de pauvre
si tu es pas crispé sur toi heureux si
tu as de la douce S et que tu ne choisis
pas la violence heureux si tu as faim et
soif de justice et cetera si tu es
fabricant de paix artisan de paix
heureux et ben il y a des gens qui ont
été détectés comme ça marche pour eux
ils ont réussi ça pas toujours pas
partout regardez un petit bonhomme comme
l'abbé Pierre il meurt la cathédrale de
Paris est remplie de gens
majoritairement incroyants qu'est-ce
qu'il fait que il est crédible sur un
point pas surt he parce que c'était un
prêtre comme moi et je vais dire comme
vous c'est un prêtre tout simple mais ça
ce sera une autre question alors ça sera
une autre question mais il a été
crédible parce que heureux ceux qui
arrivent à épencher leur joie de croire
sur une qualité d'amour pour tout le
monde donc crédible et rassembleur
crédible et rassembleur et détecté par
le peuple tout simple et après
authentifié je dirais par la hiérarchie
de l'Église qui dit oui effectivement
bon donc on continue encore à à canonisé
vous ah oui oui il a encore jours voilà
Jacques bertux je crois qui est mort à
Madagascar en
1896 je crois bon il y en a oui oui
régulièrement le plus typique si vous
voulez un exemple qui était très
intéressant c'est à la mort de Jean-Paul
II il y avait des grandes affiche dans
le peuple qui disait Santo subito ce qui
veut dire allez tout de suite ça
sanctifiez-le tout de suite hein c'est
quoi ça c'est le peuple de Dieu qui
repère que dans cet homme qui avait ses
ambigués aussi hein et ben celui-là il
est crédible voyez c'est un comme vous
avez dit rassembleur crédible du point
de vue de cette vie de
Jésus-Christ pour cette fête du 2
novembre qui la fête des défuns est-ce
que les les familles vous demandent des
messes particulières est-ce que c'est un
moment de de recueillement ce oui oui
les gens le demandent vraiment et pas
que les personnes croyantes les
municipalités tiennent beau tiennent
beaucoup à ce qu'ils soit ils sont dans
la laïcité hein donc il y a pas de messe
pour eux mais il y a des de demande il y
a des présences de de conseil
conseillers municipaux on dit souvent
les morts de la guerre et cetera il y a
quelque chose quand même qui est dans
cette fête très liée à la au souvenir et
d'une vie plus forte que tout mais il y
a une prière particulière pour ce 2
novembre ah oui oui ou ah oui oui oui il
y a tout un rituel particulier qui sont
des textes de la Bible et qui sont des
horisons qui sont tout typiqu oui oui
oui oui ah oui oui la mort a une grande
place dans la vie he parce qu'elle dit
la résurrection dans notre foi alors
justement vous parle de la Résurrection
on va parler dans quelques instants avec
Gastine du marché de la crémation alors
justement quel regard vous l'Église
catholique vous portez sur la crémation
puisque a priori au départ si on choisit
la crémation c'est parce qu'on ne croit
pas en la résurrection alors non ça a
été à la fin du 19e siècle il y a eu un
mouvement oui le début du mouvement a
été ça hein on ne croit pas à la
résurrection la preuve c'est qu'on va se
faire incinérer bon l'Église a dit bah
si c'est ça benah c'est clair soyez
honnête on célèbre pas l'église c'est
plus du tout ça la question maintenant
la question maintenant bon que peut-être
des spécialistes pourront vous dire moi
je connais moins et moi de mon point de
vue c'est pas la vraie réponse ou la
seule de mon point de vue il y a un
malaise dans la société actuelle par
rapport au corps hein et on ne supporte
pas un corps qui s'abîme qui vieillit
qui est tordu qui et cetera et encore
pire quand le corps est mort qui bouge
plus et qui devient moche et qui pue
hein et et je P on
préfère être incinéré comme ça on je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose chose de
ça je dis pas dans l'idée on garde un
souvenir plutôt agréable de la personne
on évite de penser à l'idée qu'elle
puisse être en TER je pense qu'il y a
mais ça traduit un malaise de toute
notre société actuelle dans sa relation
au corps sur les obsèes que vous
célébrez dans dans les paroisses de
morpa et lancour vous vous avez beaucoup
de demandes enfin les familles vous
disent que ensuite le corps va être
parce que ça elles sont pas obligé de
vous dire OUI OUI à proportion à peu
près de des statistiques actuelles un
petit peu moins sans doute mais et non
non il y a régulièrement on le fait
avant la crémation quand le corps est
encore là écoutez merci Père chisan vous
allez rester en plateau avec nous on va
continuer cette émission on va parler du
marché de la crémation mais tout de
suite je vous propose un autre sujet qui
na absolument rien à voir nous allons
partir à MPa pour suivre un cours de
danse country réservé à des personnes en
situation de
handicap cours de danse particulier pour
danseurs d'un jour asion de la semaine
du handicap qui se déroulait à Plaisir
l'association cowboy ADV dancers
proposait une initiation à la country à
des adultes handicapés mentaux et moteur
issus du foyer de Villepreux il faut
faire des adaptations de chorégraphie
parce que le but est c'est que comme
j'ai une association avec trois niveaux
de danse
différents j'aimerais que mes débutants
valident et mes débutant fauteuil
fassent les mêmes danses donc il faut
faire des adaptations de chorégraphie
pour qu'il puissent danser ensemble sur
la même piste de danse partager la même
piste de danse danse en ligne en cercle
la country comme certaines danses
latines permet de voir valides et
personnes handicapées se rejoindre sur
une même piste séduit par ses premiers
pas en rythme et leur nouveaux partenair
les apprentis danseurs se sentent
ordinaire le temps d'une danse et
s'affiche sous un nouveau jour on a vu
un résident qui d'habitude est assez
réfractaire à ce qu'on lui dit et tout
et là il écoute toutes les
du premier coup donc c'est super quoi ou
on les découvre autrement aussi habitué
au mur de leur foyer ces adultes
handicapés étaient particulièrement
enthousiaste à l'annonce de cette sortie
singulière pour les plus mordus
l'association cowboy dancers a déjà
ouvert un cours le samedi matin pour les
personnes porteuses d'un handicap moteur